What up, what up, what up, herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge, das Podcast Sufo mit Stieft.
Hey, ich bin auch wieder dabei, aufgeladen, die Gag-Kanone ist geladen und ente sichern, will ich sagen.
Mir gegenüber sitzt der fantastische Florin Z.
Will, herzlich willkommen auch dir.
Dankeschön, nein, herzlich willkommen an dich, vielen Dank.
Nein, herzlich willkommen an dich.
Du hast mir heute so nett die Tür aufgehalten, Stefan. Das hat mich echt gefreut.
Du, ich habe mich gefreut, dass immer wieder da bist, dass wir wieder reinschleissen.
30% hören nach einer Folge aber sofort auf.
Aber sowas vor.
Aber die hören dann nie wieder rein.
Wow, aber das fliegt raus sofort.
Ich bin oft da gewesen und spreche Italienisch fliessend, deswegen an meine lieben Freunde, ciao! Im Raum hier ist Stefan Titzibitzi Titzler. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge Das Podcast UFO, mittlerweile dann auch schon Folge 224, in die uns Nils die Tür geöffnet hat. Er hat die Tür geöffnet, hat gesagt, komm rein, Freunde. String nochmal hier in dem Intro. Also erst haben wir Nils die Tür aufgemacht, dann ist er in den Flur ein Stück vorgegangen und hat die nächste Tür. Wir gesagt, wir werden keine Schuhe anziehen hier, er hat die Schuhe ausgezogen.
Dann hat er die nächste Tür für uns aufgemacht und dann, das ist ja eigentlich die Etikette, dass man sich immer abwechselnd die Tür aufmacht.
Man macht die Türen auf.
Im Grunde schon.
Und Türen wieder zu.
Ne, Türen zumachen ist eigentlich keine Kunst.
Also die Kunst ist schon, Tür aufmachen ist schon, Tür zumachen hat was Blockierendes.
Ja, das stimmt, dafür sind Türen auch da, glaube ich.
Dass man irgendwann sagt, lass uns mal zwischen unseren beiden Büroräumen eine Tür bauen. In meiner neuen Wohnung habe ich eine Tür. Da bin ich da eine Minute und du bist bei deiner neuen Wohnung. Das ist wirklich der Rekord. Das ist bei Türen, da ist man schnell bei Wohnungen, da ist man schnell bei... Ich kitzle dich ja auch immer, ich fange ja auch immer an mit, du Teppiche sind schon... Grundsteinlegung, du, Stichwort Grundstein. Aber da habe ich so eine Mini-Abstellkammer, die ist ganz winzig, aber es hat so eine vollwertige Tür davor. Also wirklich mit so einem krassen Rahmen und wie man das kennt, so Metallrahmen und so Metallgriffe. Und so eine richtig vollwertige Tür. Und es gehört sich, ich finde, Türen müssen im Verhältnis stehen zu dem, was sie verbergen. Du meinst dann eigentlich nur so eine Katzenklappe, für einen kleinen Raum auch nur eine kleine Tür, ganz klein wie so ein Playmobilhaus. Und dann muss man halt gucken, wie man reinkommt. Oder wenn schon so eine Größe hat, also so eine Höhe hat zumindest, dann doch wenigstens sehr dünnes Holz, dünnes, billiges Holz. Oder sehr schmale Tür, schon normale Höhe, aber halt wirklich so, dass man sich seitlich drehen muss, um durchzukommen. Die Tür muss im Verhältnis zum Raum stehen, so wie Hogwarts zum Beispiel. Hogwarts hat eine imposante Tür, aber es ist auch ein imposantes Schloss. Da kann man dahinter, da ist ja viel zu entdecken. Du triggert mich schon wieder mit Hogwarts, weil ich habe... Wow, nach fünf Minuten redest du wieder von Harry Potter, so nämlich, so nämlich, um den Spießzudrehen. Ja, ist wirklich so. Aber es ist wirklich so, man überlegt sich ja, womit verbringt man sein Leben. Jeder Mensch hat so ein paar Jährchen auf dieser wunderschönen, kugeligen, blaugrünen Erde Zeit. Die Erde. Und dann guckt man halt, was man so macht. Und ich erlebe immer mehr, dass es immer weiter aus meiner Hand gleitet, womit ich meine Zeit verbringe. Es wird immer mehr fremdbestimmt. Mein Beispiel, einen Tag dieser Woche habe ich damit verbracht, einem Ohrwurm hinterher zu jagen. Ich hatte einen Ohrwurm und... Hast du den noch im Kopf? Kannst du nachmachen? Ja. So, und dann ist die Frage, also, du kaltest das Lied,
du könntest es nicht zuordnen.
Ja, der Stuhl quietscht gewaltig. Eine Erschütterung geht durch Ehrenfeld. Und durch Podcast Deutschland. Frage, du konntest, wie lang war der Ohrwurm? Also der Ohrwurm war schon so eine gute vier Takte lang. Gute vier Takte lang. Nie länger, ne? Nie länger. Und dann macht man natürlich das, was man immer macht. Man googelt zwei, drei erste Dinge, die in einem einfallen. Und dann geht man auf eine dieser erbärmlichen Voice-Erkennungsseiten, wo man wirklich schon, auch da geht man sehr, auf manche Webseiten geht man ja einfach durch die Tür durch und sagt, Leute, was geht, hallo, Facebook, Twitter, hier bin ich. Auf manche Webseiten geht man so ganz schüchtern so, Entschuldigung, hallo, oh, bin ich hier richtig? Ich suche ein Lied. Und dann direkt so Werbung, Cash Casino, Cash Casino! Wenn du ein Typ, so ein Verrückter, der dich anschreit. Ja, genau. So ein kleiner Raum, wo man sich reinwagt, und dann springt so ein Gnoben Kobold in die Ecke. Und dann muss man ihn wegdrücken. So ein irischer, mit so einem vierblätterigen Kleeblatt. Hi! Hi, Rates! Nein, danke. Und dann bist du in so einer riesigen Lobby, wo ganz hinten jemand sagt, ja... Hier, einfach vor... Ja? Bin ich richtig? Okay. Und dann heißt es... Websites where we're room. Ja? Sketch-Reihe. Finde ich gut. Webs website is a webroom. Welcome to a new episode of a website is a room. A website is a webroom. A website is a room. Diese YouTube-Serie, die ich letztens geschaut habe, die ist so gut. Wie hässt sie denn? A website is a room. Noch mal bitte? A website is a webroom. Hat auch jemand auf Twitter geschrieben, ihr habt da in Folge hundertmal irgendwie einen Podcast empfohlen, den habe ich akustisch nicht verstanden. Und dann wir hören es nach. Was? Wir haben es auch nicht verstanden, dass es der Sinn von Empfehlungen gibt. Und dann geht man halt auf so erbärmliche Seiten, auf denen man nicht gerne ist. Niemand ist gerne auf so einer Website. Und alte Regel, ja, Algorithmen sind ja nur Inder, wie wir immer gesagt haben, eine Horde Inder. Genau. Ich will nicht, was noch ein Zitat war, aber es stellt sich ja raus, dass viele Algorithmen, die gemeinhin als tolle Programme und so Coats beschrieben werden, oft einfach nur so eine Art Render-Farm ist, wo Inder dann das Amazon durchsuchen nach dem Produkt, was du fotografiert hast, zum Beispiel. Im Grunde ist jeder KI-Algorithmus eigentlich nur eine direkte Telefonleitung nach Neu-Delhi. Und da klingelt ein Telefon, wenn ich sage, ja jetzt summ sie ihr Lied und dann guckst du dich halt so um und dann... Harry Potter. So, du weisst das, du hast es er du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du Nächste Woche, falls euch irgendein Song nicht einfällt, schickt ihn an Stefan Tietze und dann haben wir eine Statistik, wie viele du richtig erkannt hast und welche nicht. Weil das ist, da will ich dich jetzt callen, weil da... Weil Hogwarts March, also gut, sehr speziell... Ich meine, natürlich kenne ich den Hogwarts March auch, aber mir ist er halt nicht eingefallen. Ich habe mir deswegen eine Trompete gekauft, um den auf der Trompete zu lernen. Stellt sich heraus, unlernbar, schwierig, sehr schwierig. Stellt sich heraus, ist auch eine Querflöte drin.
Stellt sich heraus, auch ein Tumpa.
Ja, sämtliche Instrumente sind leider da drin.
Das ist eine Cash-Kau.
Also wie viele Musikläden haben da Millionen verdient an diesem Hogwarts-Match? Aber ich verstehe, woher der O-O-O-O-M kommt und das nicht zuordnen können, weil es ist ja nicht die Hauptmelodie, es ist der B-Teil.
Richtig, es ist der B-Teil und Filmmusik ist halt immer tückisch,
weil Filmmusik ja oft andere Genres imitieren, sagen wir mal,
oder irgendwie dann so einen Marsch hat, wo man nicht genau weiß,
ist das jetzt ein echter Marsch?
Und dann habe ich natürlich, der Algorithmus hat natürlich gesagt so, Heidi Minogue, Mariah Carey, mir liegt es auf der Zunge, aber ich weiß, sorry, ich kaff es gerade auch nicht drauf. Und dann irrst er halt stundenlang durchs Internet, irgendwann habe ich es dann gefunden, Hogwarts March, und dann dachte ich mir auch. Wie war deine Reaktion, wenn man das dann findet, nach drei Stunden? Ach ja, klar!
Und dann dachte ich mir, weißt du was, fuck it, der Tag ist eh schon angebrochen, der Tag war eh schon fast rum, es war jetzt 16.30 Uhr oder so, Tag ist im Eimer.
Im Kern hat doch ein Tag, also zwei brauchbare Stunden.
Du wachst auf, kommst erst mal an dem Tag.
Genau.
Erst mal Frühstück, scrollen.
Wenn du, also erst mal gucken, was mache ich so frühstücken, gehe ich frühstücken, mache ich frühstücken, kommst erst mal an dem Tag. Genau. Erst mal Frühstück, scrollen.
Also ich will gucken, was mache ich zu frühstücken.
Gehe ich frühstücken, mache ich frühstücken.
Da ist schon drei zu neun.
Dann ist schon fast Mittagspause.
Ja, und dann hast du eigentlich schon ein gutes Gewissen, weil Frühstück habe ich gemacht.
Ja, das war auch schon Arbeit.
Also da habe ich noch schon gedanklich.
Ich habe sogar auch schon die Cornflakeschüssel direkt abgewaschen, um mich gut zu fühlen für den Rest des Tages.
Ja, also den Abend habe ich frei.
Genau, dafür nehme ich mir jetzt den Abend mal schön frei. Und dann dachte ich mir, und dann habe ich halt so gedacht an diesen august march wie cool das ist und wie der halt von der ersten dass du diese melodie so schön fandest ja die so schön aber die ist so und wie der halt von der ersten bis zur letzten sekunde einfach knallt dieser august und der lief den ganzen tag dann auf lautstärke 69 ja total und dann dachte ich mir habe ich an diese szene gedacht weil die sieht man nur einmal im film sieht man diesen Hogwarts-Marsch. Und der lief den ganzen Tag dann auf Lautstärke 69. Ja, total. Und dann dachte ich mir, habe ich an diese Szene gedacht, weil die sieht man nur einmal im Film, sieht man diesen Hogwarts-Marsch. Dann habe ich mir halt nochmal Harry Potter 4 angeguckt. Und dann dachte ich mir am Ende des Tages, dieser gesamte Tag war jetzt nur bestimmt von diesem Rohrwurm. Also ich habe an diesem Tag kaum eine Entscheidung getroffen. Ich war in so einer Wildwasserbahn und bin irgendwann mal eingestiegen in diese Wildwasserbahnwand des Tages. Und dann habe ich halt nur noch aus dem Fenster geschaut. Also ich wurde gezogen. Wurde es ein bisschen nass auch eigentlich? Wurde auch ein bisschen nass. Und eigentlich war dieser Tag nicht meiner. Eigentlich müsste ich den irgendwie wieder zurückfordern können, dass ich sage, Entschuldigung, kann ich den Tag zurückbekommen? Irgendeine Behörde müsste mir diesen Tag zurückgeben.
Weil eigentlich wurde mir dieser Tag geraubt.
Von der Mutterbewusstsein. Von irgendwas, von irgendeiner Hupe draußen, die und dann halt irgendwie hat es das ausgelöst oder so. So klingen Hupen ja auch natürlich. Einfach die ganze Zeit so. Und dann habe ich mir nochmal Harry Potter 4 hingeguckt. Und das hat mich auch wieder so beschäftigt, weil da so viele merkwürdige Szenen drin sind. Ich habe auch das Gefühl, ganz kurz nochmal. Driftet ab. Für mich ist Harry Potter 4 der letzte Teil. Weil es ist ja immer so, es gibt... Im Sinne von das letzte oder... Nein, der letzte Teil. Weil es gibt ja immer so bei so Filmreihen so Boxen, die man sich kaufen kann mit mehr als einem Filmteil. Und merkwürdigerweise, also gibt dann so die Harry Potter Komplettbox, wo alle DVDs drin sind. Merkwürdigerweise gibt es diese Boxen auch schon, bevor die Serie abgeschlossen ist. Also wenn der sechste Teil rauskommt, kannst du dir eine Box kaufen, Harry Potter 1 bis 6. Wir wollen ja den Cash nicht mitnehmen für die Blu-rays und für die Box-Blu-rays. Und ich habe mir damals unerklärlicherweise die Box 1 bis 4 gekauft. Ich wusste, dass es 5, 6 alles gibt, dass sie noch kommen werden. Und es gibt ja keine Box fünf bis acht, sondern... Aber jetzt könnten die ja dann einfach für die letzten Filme dann das gleiche Blu-Ray-Disc-Design anbieten. Ja. Und dann halt den Karton, in dem alle reingestopft sind. Weil das ist ja auch Wahnsinn. Du hast ja den Karton außen, und dann hast du die einzelnen Dinger, die da reingesteckt werden. werden. Und dann kannst du ja theoretisch den äusseren Karton ersetzen. Im Grunde schon, aber dann müsstest du halt eine Box verkaufen, die ist fünf bis, ich weiß nicht wie viel, es gibt sieben oder acht, fünf bis sieben. Aber das macht halt keiner, du verkaufst halt keine Box drei bis acht, zwei bis neun, zwei bis sieben oder nur zwei, drei und vier. Und vier musst du immer doppelt kaufen. Das ist nämlich mein Trick. Es gibt eins bis vier und vier bis neun. Und deswegen hatte ich immer nur die DVDs von eins bis vier und dachte halt, vier ist der letzte Teil. Aber unbefriedigendes Ende. Merkwürdiger Film. Also ganz unbefriedigendes Ende. Aber apropos unbefriedigend, ich habe mir überlegt, wie lame dieses trimagische Turnier ist für die Schüler in Hogwarts, für die Zuschauer. Zum Beispiel, du hast ja dieses Labyrinth-Wettbewerb, wo der Hogwarts-March gespielt wird, alle Tribüne, alle drei Schulen sitzen da, vor allem ihre Champions an, und dann rennen die los in das Labyrinth, Hogwarts-March spielt und dann du du du du du. Ja. Und dann starb man zwei Stunden lang auf diese grüne Hecke. Ja, ja, und ab und zu kommt aber so ein ...
Nichts passiert. Ja, gut. Aber ein bisschen lamer noch als Formel-1, wo man am Start dann so die, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, neig unbefrieden. Vielleicht aber so große, so, weiß ich nicht, Leute, die kommentieren, oder Gandalf hat das kommentiert, nehmen wir an. Ja, auch interessant. Ich glaube schon, Gandalf auf seinem Falken oben fliegt drüber und sagt, jetzt ist er reingelaufen in den Schlingfaden. Nein, aber jetzt ist er schon wieder raus. Jetzt habe ich es auch nicht gesehen. Und dann denken sie, und dann vor allem die Challenge davor, unter Wasser. Ähnlich cool für Zuschauer, ganz awkward, es kommt raus auf den Steg und dann, go Harry, go und pfff. Aber es fing gut an in dieser Arena mit dem Drachen, mega. Drachen war geil, mega geil, die haben extra eine Arena, die Drachen, cool. Und dann, alter, die nächste Challenge muss man uns anschauen.
Die nächste Challenge ist im Dunkeln, die nächste ist im Wasser, die nächste ist im Wald, die nächste ist in einem anderen Land, die nächste ist in diesem anderen Schloss, wo diese Russen hergekommen sind, die jetzt bei uns sind, da ist die andere Prüfung.
Ich hätte es mir so gewünscht, dass die Kamera, wenn die alle ins Wasser springen und die Challenge starten, dass die Kamera beim Publikum bleibt.
Weil die alle go, here we go, dann springen die alle ins Wasser und das Publikum dann ein bisschen trüb. Na gut. Kann ich doch von diesen Oreos haben? Ja, klar. Nimm dir. Ist noch einer. Go Harry! Oh, da ist Blasen auf hochgekommen. Oh, ist das ein gutes Zeichen? Nee, ist... Gehen wir nochmal zum Schloss oder bleiben wir jetzt hier bis...
Wie lange geht das Spiel?
Es hieß bis acht Stunden, ich weiß nicht, Spaß.
Die können doch nicht so lange Luft anhalten.
Muggel haben ja, habe ich mal gehört, so...
Wie was dann?
Nee, so ein Kanister auf dem Rücken, dann können die länger tauchen.. Echt? Krass. Die wären gar nicht so schlecht in dieser Prüfung. Manchmal überlege ich mir, ob Muggeln nicht besser wäre, weil die haben echt schnelle Autos. Wenn du nicht mehr überlegst, was wir so für Autos haben und Kutschen und so ein Quatsch. Da kannst du mir so, die du mit Eulen schickst, kannst du es halt ohne Eule schicken.
Wie?
Und ohne Brief.
Taube oder was?
Das geht so magisch, von einem so einem Gerät ins andere Gerät.
Mit einer Taube dann oder was?
Nee, mit so Dingen, die um die Erde kreisen.
Und hast du dich auch manchmal gefragt, was das für komische Dinge sind, die manchmal über uns fliegen?
Ja, ganz merkwürdig.
Das ist merkwürdig, oder wie so grosse Streifen, die sich her erziehen.
Das ist total merkwürdig. Weil magische Welt, ich wäre gerne ein Muggel. Ich wäre wirklich gerne ein Muggel, ja. Ich habe gehört, da kommt eine Filmreihe raus über so ein Muggelkind. Wirklich? Ja, über so einen Zauberer, der dann herausfindet, dass er ein Muggel ist. Und der mit elf Jahren auf die weiterführende Schule Wurzweiler geht. Wird er dann von so einem Muggel, von einem grossen Muggel abgeholt und wird dann auf die Waldorfschule gesteckt. Megagut. Und da lernt er dann so krasse Sachen. Ja, und da kommt er dann, ist das die Frage, welche Klasse kommt er? Ja. Dann kommt er in die B. In die Igelgruppe. Nicht die Igelgruppe! Nicht die Igelgruppe! Aber die haben keine Korridore und so keine Häuser, sondern die haben einfach so, ist einfach so ein normales Schulgebäude. Voll krass. Aber die haben dann Informatik und da sind mega geil. Dann stell dir das mal vor, was du da für geile Sachen lernen kannst. Holy shit. Wir haben schon die geilere Welt. Eigentlich ist es schon besser, ja. Ja, sie versteht auch diese ganzen Potterheads nicht nicht mit ihren großen, doch ich verstehe es, diese Voltschals.
Die Schals machen eigentlich alles. Und vor allem, ich habe dann natürlich einen Deep Drive gemacht zum Thema Hogwarts March und habe natürlich auch viele Fanversionen gefunden, wo die irgendwie in einem Feld stehen mit vier Schals und dann den Hogwarts March spielen. Grandios, fantastisch. Aus einem Haus oder aus vier Häusern?
Seid ihr aus zwei Häusern. Also Gryffindor und Hufflepuff, die passen ja noch einigermaßen gut zusammen. Weil Mut und Freundschaft passen ganz gut zusammen. Leute, kann ich auch mitkommen, passt eigentlich auch ganz gut zusammen. Von daher eigentlich eine gute Idee. Aber ja, es ist schwierig. Ich fände Teil 4 gar nicht gut. Auch diese 4 auch schwierig. Heutertag können sie so einen Film auch nicht mehr machen mit diesen ganzen hotten Französinnen und diesen ganzen roughen osteuropäischen Jungs, die an da kommen. Ja, ist doof. Aber, also gibt es denn nicht so auch eine, also jetzt mal, klar, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, man denkt nur an sich, aber gibt es nicht eine deutsche Zauberer Schule? Da müssen alle Europäer nach England kommen oder was?
Nein, nicht Domstrang, kann man nicht.
Domstrang in Deutschland oder was?
Nee, Domstrang ist nicht Deutschland, Domstrang ist ja irgendwo Ukraine oder sowas.
Aber gibt es, müssen dann, also vor allem auch in Hogwarts-Series.
Dort ist es wahrscheinlich aber irgendwie so ein Restaurant irgendwo.
Nee, aber ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es wirklich so aussieht wie so meine Schule damals. Ja, genau. Und es gibt doch keine Häuser, sondern einfach wirklich Parallelklassen. Ich bin einfach sehr pragmatisch und so. Ja, wir machen halt Magie, aber du würdest es ja früher von außen nicht ansehen. Nee, null. Null, du hast so eine schöne Brandschutztreppe, so eine schöne Metall-Brandschutztreppe links, so das, das sticht so ein bisschen raus. Aber auf Hogwarts sind ja nur Briten eigentlich. Wo sind alle anderen Europäer dann? Ja, mega. Also ich habe jetzt die Harry Potter, genau, wie heißt das nochmal? Bödo, Bö, Bollolol, Bollol, Bollol, Französische Namen sind einfach nur Säben. Bordog, Bordi, Bollol, und wie Burs betrifft das? Bordog, Bollol,, ich habe jetzt mal Deutschland angegeben, und zwar im Harry Potter-Wiki.
Deutschland ist ein Land in Mitteleuropa.
Generell, übrigens ein Funfact-Tipp da draußen, wenn ihr irgendwie Länder googelt oder so was, belanglose Dinge, googelt die mal in einem Fan-Wiki von irgendwas.
Zum Beispiel Harry Potter.
Oder wenn ihr ein historisches Thema recherchiert, irgendwie so was November-Revolution, nicht auf Wikipedia geht, sondern hier, Jedipedia, November-Revolution. Die sind oft besser geschrieben. Wobei auch da der große Kampf zwischen Wookiepedia und Jedipedia. Ja, ähnlich wie bei Pokémon hast du ja auch Bisa Friends und Poképedia, keine Ahnung, das sind auch zwei konkurrierende. Ich habe diesen Kampf hinter mir gelassen, ich habe das brennende Gebäude verlassen. Deutschland ist ein Land in Mitteleuropa, es grenzt im Norden, ich will mal gucken, wann auch der magische Aspekt reinkommt, es grenzt im Norden an die Nordsee, Dänemark, im Nordosten an die Ostsee, im Osten an Polen, im Südosten an Tschechien, im Süden an Österreich, oh, Ungarn, Slowenien, stimmt ja nicht, Italien, Italien, Italien auch nicht, Liechtenstein und an die Schweiz, Im Südwesten an Frankreich, im Westen an Luxemburg, im Nordwesten an Belgien, die Hauptstadt ist Berlin. Die wechselhafte Geschichte der Deutschen, besonders vor dem internationalen Geheimhaltungsabkommen, lässt auch andere Städte als Tagungsorte der Reichstage des Heiligen Römischen Reiches Deutschlands zu tun. Wir sind auf der Harry Potter Wikipedia wohlgemerkt. Weitere Großstelle sind Dresden, Frankfurt und Main. Ja gut, alles klar. Von dort stammt Gellert Grindelwald und seine Familie. Nein, der Böse kommt aus Deutschland? Natürlich. Ist Grindelwald nicht der? Jetzt kommt eine Liste bekannter Persönlichkeiten. Kirsten Blyke, Jäger im nationalen Quidditch-Team. Igor Brandt, Jäger im nationalen Quidditch-Team. Elena Eldricht, Schlägerin im nationalen Quidditch-Team, äh, wir sind eine Quidditch-Mal... Schlägerin! Gellert Grindelwald, Dunkler Lord, Erbauer der Gefängnisfestung von Normengard, Katharina von Glockenspieler, Schläger im nationalen Quidditch-Team, äh, Paselmund, so, jetzt, politisches System, nee, das traue ich mir nicht vorzulesen, ah doch, Deutschland wird durch ein Zaubereiministerium geregiert. An der Spitze amtiert ein gewählter Zauberminister oder ein Bundesminister für Magie. Inwieweit in Deutschland ein Bundestag, Bundesgerichtshof oder ein mit gesetzgebenden und judikativen Vollmachten aus der Hohe Rat der Zaubereiministerium ist bis dahin nicht bekannt geworden. Die lange Tradition eines föderalen Staatsaufbau und die resultierenden Interessenvertretungen in einen Bund lassen darauf schliessen. Moment mal, Deutschland wird von einem Zauberer auch regiert? Zaubereiministerium, ja. Vom Zaubereiminister. Oder bei Zauberei Kanzler wahrscheinlich auch. Ach, die regieren alles. Ich dachte, die sind nur so eine einzelne Branche, aber auch die sind wirklich die Regierung. In der Zauberwelt, genau. Das heißt in der Zauberwelt. Ja,ieren ja nicht das Land. England wird ja nicht von, wie heißt der, Fatsch regiert. Okay, verstehe. Aber wo kommen diese Informationen her? Hat sich das irgendjemand aus den Fingern gesaugt? Rechtscheuerväter lassen das ausschliessen. So, jetzt sehe ich die Jahreszeit 1933, das bringe ich mal. Die Erklings machen dem Ministerium besonders zu schaffen. Hä? Erklings? Was sind Erklings? Elfenhaftes Geschöpf. Das sieht fast, die machen dem Ministerium zu schaffen. Diese merkwürdigen Sideplots. Ja, aber das ist fast antisemitisch. Ich kann mir auch gut vorstellen, dass in Teil 5 mal so für zwei Seiten einfach das politische System Deutschlands erklärt wird, einfach so am Rande, einfach so während irgendwie zwei sich unterhalten, driftet der Erzähler kurz mal ab.
Oh, wir haben Riesen, also die magische Tierwelt, Einhörner, Erklings, Lindwurm, Loreley, Riesen, Werwölfe, Bergtrolle, Vampire, Quirrell.
Professor Quirrell. Professor Quirrell. Warum stehe ich bei Tierwelt? Ich habe irgendwie... Hier stand Vampire, Gerüchten zufolge begegnete Quirinus Quirrell. Der heisst nicht Quirrilius Quirrell. Quirinus Quirrell. Nein, oh Gott, wirklich. Alles auf Max gedreht, wirklich. Jede Figur ist der Regler auf zehn gedreht. Der heisst nicht nur Quirrell, der ist Quirinius Quirrell. Quirrell ist Quirrell. Und Hermine ist schlau, aber so richtig schlau. Der ist im Schwarzwald Vampiren begegnet. Auch interessant. Quidditch, das haben wir schon gecheckt, sind wir gar nicht so schlecht. Schlägerinnen, wir haben viele erfolgreiche Schlägerinnen. Aber es gibt wohl keinen Hogwarts. Ah, ganz merkwürdig. Wo geht denn Deutschland? Es gibt ja auch die amerikanische Elvermorny, Elverdings, das ist ja die amerikanische Version. Ja, ganz merkwürdig, aber auch nervig, wenn du so Worldbuilding machst in der Schule und dann kommen Leute und fragen dich, ja, aber wie ist es in Deutschland? Ja, keine Ahnung, Mann. Woher soll ich das wissen? Ja, aber warum Frankreich und warum hat Deutschland keine? Aber es ist ja auch, Harry Potter darf man jetzt auch nicht mehr so richtig geil finden. J.K. Rowling hat es ein bisschen verkackt auch. Schon eine uncoole, uncoole Alte. Ja, aber ... Muss man trennen. Macht die dann noch ... Also haut die dann noch Sachen raus? Ja, die dann noch diese Seite, wo sie an neuen Sachen hochlädt, wie so diese Ganderalfe-Schwulnummern. Ja, die Erklings wurden besiegt. Die Erklings wurden besiegt und so. Endlich. Und niemand in der ganzen Harry Potter-Welt ist trans. Niemand. Niemand. So ein Counter. Nummer von trans. Null. Still zero. Still zero. Boah, die ist echt. Ach ja. Irgendwo falsch abgebogen. Ja gut, und was machst du jetzt mit diesem Tag? Weil der ist ja jetzt erstmal passé. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich den irgendwo reklamieren kann, aber manchmal hat man ja so, so manche Tage versaut man. Aber diese Story ist immer so halb-relatable, weil du hast halt echt einfach freie Tage, was natürlich fantastisch ist. Ja, Freizeit ist toll. Und dann, was machst du denn an so einem normalen freien Tag? Also, ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass du irgendwie ein schönes Buch liest und so. Wo liest du denn zum Beispiel das Buch? Liest du dich dann in so einem Lesesessel? Ich bin ja, also ich habe ja irgendwann entschieden, und damit fahre ich ganz gut, und jetzt ist natürlich klar, werde ich Mails bekommen, dass das nicht richtig ist und bla bla bla, da kennen sich die Leute besser aus. Ich bin irgendwann umgestiegen auf zwei Mahlzeiten pro Tag. Ich esse nur noch zweimal am Tag und versuche aufzuwachen und dann möglichst lange nicht zu essen, um dann irgendwann ein richtig großes Mittagessen zu essen und abends noch was Kleines.
So, das heißt, ich wache eigentlich auf und ab dann beginnt eigentlich der Kampf gegen den Hunger. Ja, ich versuche es, solange es geht, rauszuzögern, dass wenn ich so, keine Ahnung, um zehn aufstehe, dann denke ich mir, okay, so 14 so 14 Uhr ist und dann habe ich aber um elf schon Hunger und dann kämpfe ich mental gegen den Hunger und es ist eigentlich ein Ringen mit dem Hunger über Stunden hinweg, dass ich mich herumwälze auf dem Boden und gegen mich selbst kämpfe, um diesen Hunger zu kontrollieren, bis ich dann irgendwann was esse und dann ist der Tag eigentlich schon mehr oder weniger rum, weil dann habe ich mir noch eine schöne Mate.
Und bist du auch platt.
Ich bin dann auch platt.
Bist du platt vom ganzen Kampf gegen den Hut.
Und dann hole ich mir eine Mate, die packe ich ins Gefrierfach für eine Stunde, dann muss ich erstmal eine Stunde warten.
Wie auf hessische Vergessen?
Einige Male. Packe ich sie ins Gefrierfach für eine Stunde, das dauert dann eine Stunde, dann trinke ich die, die ist recht kalt, also das dauert auch noch seine Zeit und dann ist Abend halt so. Dann hat man es eigentlich schon wieder geschafft. Man hat es hinter sich. Das klingt so, als ob du den Tag hinter dich bekommen willst. Und dann merkt man schon wieder, oh, da kommt schon wieder ein bisschen Hunger auf und dann kommt nochmal so ein schöner Abendsnack. Das war so ein lateinisches Sprichwort, also die Carpe Diem, nur für bring's hinter dich, also bring den Tag hinter dich. Ja, versuch so schnell, es ist wie so, wie so wenn man Medizin nehmen muss, man macht die Augen zu und versucht nichts zu schmecken. Augen zu und durch. Augen zu und durch im Grunde, ja. Oculus Closus, Closestrum, Ariensus, genau, sowas in der Und dann ist schon wieder Abend. Und dann gucke ich noch eine Folge Barry. Ich schaue gerade Barry, die Serie mit Bill Hader. Fantastisch. Aber eine Folge am Tag. Eine Folge am Tag. Mache ich mir schön mit dem Laptop im Bett. Und dann gucke ich halt immer, wie ich, dann habe ich so, dann stütze ich meinen Kopf auf dem linken Arm, aber das wird unangenehm nach zehn Minuten. Nee, ich lege dann den Laptop um. Nee, das mache ich nicht. Oh mein Gott. Nee, weil das ist, da komme ich nicht klar damit, dass dann irgendwie so die Raumkoordinaten sich ändern. Es gibt zwei Arten von Menschen. Es gibt die Menschen, die den Laptop so quasi 90 Grad Winkel aufklappen und dann umlegen, dass du quasi dich hinlegen kannst, das mache ich.
Finde ich fantastisch. Ja, was mich dann ärgert ist, dass man dann ja nur die linke Seite des Laptops sieht oder dass man halt nicht zentriert ist.
Und das, das irritiert mich. Man ist so zentriert. Nee, du bist ja, du liegst ja mit deinem Kopf auf dem Bett.
Und der Kopf ist auch nicht ganz so gerade, der Kopf ist ja eher so noch weiter runter geguckend.
Ja, dann habe ich halt noch so ein kleines Kissen, dann probiere ich halt so ein bisschen rum, wie ich das am besten legen kann und oft kriege ich auch einen
grossen Teil der Folge nicht mit, weil ich halt primär damit beschäftigt bin, wie genau ich dieses Kissen jetzt nehme und dann wer ist die Figur und so und dann oft schlafe ich dann ein. Und das ist mein Tag. Werbung. Ich kriege jede Woche Samstag morgens Scheld, der DPD-Fahrer, bei mir. Um sieben Uhr dreistig. Um sieben Uhr dreistig hielt er mich raus, wirklich, der ist ein bisschen penetrant, aber netter Kerl und der bringt mir jeden Samstagmorgen meine helle Freshbox. Und ich freue mich darüber jedes Mal, denn zweimal die Woche kann ich total toll kochen und alle Zutaten für diese Gerichte, das sind immer tolle Rezepte, wirklich, immer mit so einem gleichen Twist, hat man so immer noch nie gegessen, es wiederholt sich auch nichts, kriegst du dann da in dieser Box. Und wenn man das zweimal die Woche schafft, für zwei Personen habe ich das immer fantastisch, niemand hat sich immer das beschwert über das. Gut, jetzt du führst ein tolles Leben mit deiner Box, aber können wir da irgendwie auch daran teilnehmen oder ist das so eine Stefan-Alleinen-Nummer oder was? Ich habe was für euch. Wie? Unter dem Code Stefan, Stefan, Stefan, nein, unter dem Code HelloUfo bekommt ihr jetzt nämlich insgesamt, wenn ihr wollt, 45 Euro aufgeteilt auf die ersten vier Boxen, die ihr bestellt. Das ist nämlich aufgeteilt, die ersten 25 Euro gibt es für die erste Box, dann zehn auf die zweite und fünf auf die jeweils dritte und vierte. Und dann können wir so ein bisschen sein wie du. Wir können so ein bisschen mehr so sein wie ich. Wow, das ist ja mein Ziel. Und das Beste ist, es ist wirklich cool durchdacht. Also man hat kaum Müll, es gibt nur das Nötigste, es ist aus Plastik, die Kühlakkus sind aus Wasser, was man dann für die Pflanzen gießen benutzen kann, also es ist wirklich durchdacht und ökologisch cool, alles aus beschleifeltem Zeug, also macht schon Sinn und man denkt an die Umwelt. Viel Spaß mit HelloFresh! Werbung! Wie, aber so Plots von Filmen und Serien und so, extrem schlecht so gut hin. Ich habe echt Angst vor schwierigen Filmen, weil ich Plots nie verstehe. Und es ist wirklich in meinem Leben. Wir waren zusammen. Wir waren zusammen. Wir waren zusammen. Flote und ich haben zusammen einen Film, den man durchaus als nicht so einfach nachzuvollziehen bezeichnen kann. Tenet, geschaut. Und ab und zu habe ich mit diesem, weil ich weiß ja, dass Florentin oft auch Probleme mit dem Plotz hat, auch mit einfachem Plotz. Auch Probleme hat, auch nach dem Kino nicht unbedingt nacherzählen kann. Null. Es ist so, manchmal schaue ich mit anderen Leuten Filme an oder Serien und die sagen dann so, ach krass, der ist jetzt der Bruder oder was? Und ich bin so komplett lost. Ich denke noch, ich dachte, die träumen gerade. Weil ich glaube nämlich, dass wir zu viel, also es ist arrogant, aber wir sind, nein, weil wir, ja, entweder war wir auch vielleicht zu, wir sind ja beide nicht blöd, so, eigentlich, man müsste ja eigentlich, man müsste ja eigentlich davon ausgehen. Aber sagen dumme Leute nicht auch, dass sie nicht dumm sind? Ja, ja, aber die sind ja dumm. Ach so, okay. Ja, so und dann habe ich nur das Gefühl, dass wir vielleicht immer schon ein bisschen weiterdenken, so Traum, Stichwort Traum, auch weil wir auch selber kreativ arbeiten, vielleicht auch so eine Fantasie mitbringen, so eine, uns fallen, wir haben so ein, wir gucken auch eher auf so kleine Details, ich finde manchmal andere Sachen viel spannender, als dann den Plot unbedingt so. Und deswegen glaube ich, haben wir da vielleicht kein Auge für. Ist aber arrogant für, wir sind einfach nur blöd. Nee, es ist wirklich so, und ich habe auch das Problem, ich kann mich nicht so leicht gehen lassen. Und oft, wenn ich eine Sache im Film nicht verstehe, dann denke ich da immer noch drüber nach, während der Film schon weiterläuft.
Tenant ist ja das beste Beispiel. Ich bin immer noch beim Intro mit diesem Opernhaus. Warum war das Warner Brothers Logo jetzt rot? Da war es so noch. Ja genau, der Trailer für Mulan. Wann kommt der Film aus? Habe ich nicht verstanden. Und der Film ist schon halb rum. Und es war fantastisch, weil manchmal, es gibt ja so Momente im Kino, da ist dann die Leinwand plötzlich hell und man kann so ein bisschen einen Blick ins Publikum wagen.
Und da habe ich mir manchmal, weil ich ja um diese Schwäche von Device, ab und zu meinen so hellen Momenten so mal rüber gestielt. Die meine dunkelsten Momente waren. Florentin sass wirklich kerzengerade auf seinem Sitz, Augen streng nach vorne gerichtet und mit so einem, aber die Hand am Kinn und dann so ein, was passiert hier, Blick, so ein, aber ich bin immer noch, ich hänge Minute eins fest. Es ist ja wirklich so, gerade bei Tenet ist es ja so, dass alle sich damit überschlagen, zu betonen, wie sie den Film verstanden haben und wie unglaublich kongruent er ist und das ist alles in sich stimmig und ich denke mir, beigt euch, ihr habt nichts verstanden und jeder muss betonen, wie unglaublich einfach zu verstehen es war und so und kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Ich saß in dem Kino und ich habe gespürt, wie der gesamte Raum nichts verstanden hat, gar nichts und weggedriftet ist so und das ist so, man bräuchte Man hat es ziemlich deutlich gespürt, als der Film angehalten wurde und dann so eine Fragerunde losging. Ja. Ganz kurz mal eben. Hat irgendwer verstanden? Aber sowas hätte ich gebraucht. Ja, ich auch. So alle zehn Minuten, vier Minuten Schwarzbild. So, weil ich gucke ja auch gerade, ich lenne ja auch gerade Französisch und da gibt es dann so ein Plug-in für Netflix, das ist halt immer übersetzt und dann auch immer in Deutsch und in Französisch untertitelt. Und du kannst einstellen, dass nach jedem Satz der Film angehalten wird, was halt gut, nervig ist ein Wort. Seit einem Monat versuche ich, Herr der Ringe zwei zu gucken. Ja, und es ist wirklich immer so, und dann noch mal im Untertitel, ich denke, wir sollten unbedingt, ach so, so und dann kannst du noch mal reflektieren, was gerade gesagt wurde. Und genau das hätte ich mir bei Tendon auch gewünscht, so nach jedem Satz, so zehn Sekunden Pause und du so, die Zeit dreht sich um. Invertiert, wenn es nicht invertiert. Aber es gibt ja so Szenen, das ist ja spannend, bei Filmen gibt es ja oft so Szenen, gerade bei so Action-Packed-Filmen, wo eine Crew ab und zu hinzukommt, dass man oder jetzt, dann war ja bei Tannin, da gab es dann die Frau, der dann zwischendurch auch noch mal alles erklärt. Ja, die war super. Und diese Szenen, ja, aber meistens skippt man die ja dann als Drehbuchautor oder im Schnitt spätestens, weil du sagst, der Zuschauer soll nicht noch mal gelangweilt werden mit dem ganzen Exposition-Scheiß. Und dann werden diese Szenen übersprungen, meistens so ein, ich erklär's dir noch mal, Cut, Action-Szene. Weil, warum soll man das alles noch mal hören? Oder wenn eine Figur bei Game of Thrones so häufig so andere wieder einholt, andere Charaktere. Und dann so ein, was ist in der Zwischenzeit geschehen, ja, ich erklär's dir, Lagerfeuerbild, Establisher, Blende, whatever. Bei diesem Film habe ich so gehofft, dass sie es mal stehen lassen würden, und die haben sie immer weggeskippt. Ja, es gibt am Anfang hier, Bella Lafleur kommt als Wissenschaftlerin und erklärt, wie dieses Grundkonzept des Invertierens funktioniert. Fleur de la Cour. Fleur de la Cour. Und ich dachte mir, perfekt, ich bin ein kluger Mensch. Solange mir das erklärt wird, höre ich zu und verstehe das auch. Stellt sich raus, nach zehn Minuten, das war's mit Erklärung. Danach wird nie wieder irgendwas erklärt und man muss einfach gucken, wie man klarkommt. Ja, man muss klarkommen. Du bist on your own und musst dann da durch den Film paddeln. Es ist wirklich immer so, wie wenn jemand der Quantenphysik erklärt und so die ersten drei Minuten denkt man sich, ja, das geht ja, das kriege ich hin und dann so der nächste und dann hast du so einen Knick, so Moment, was war das gerade Neutronen, Proton, ich bin ganz und dann ist die weg, Zug ist weg und du rennst dann nur noch hinterher und bist nur noch, ah, der hat jetzt gerade Neutrum, ausser Atem, wo, wo, wo, und dann einfach keine Chance mehr. Und dann gibt es auch so andere, da haben sich aber auch andere im Kino manchmal auch falsche, falsche komplizierte Dinge fokussiert zum Beispiel. Dann gibt es diese Szene mit den beiden Katamaranen, die fahren, ja, und dann heben die natürlich ab, weil da unten drunter haben die diese Tragfläche und deswegen, wenn die schnell sind, heben die ab und das ganze Kino so, hä, und wie soll das jetzt funktionieren? Und ich so, nee, nee, das ist nicht kompliziert, das ist wirklich so.
Wo man natürlich auch, dadurch, dass man die Grundprämisse des Films nicht versteht, alles nicht mehr versteht, dann zeigt jemand einen Magneten und alle so, hä, wie funktioniert die denn?
Ist der invertiert? Oder warum geht das jetzt? Vor jemandem so ein Fallschirm? Hä, warum fällt der nicht runter? Der fällt nicht einfach runter. Ist die Luft invertiert? Ich war allein schon so stolz, dass ich das Wort invertiert festhalten konnte in meinem Kopf, dass das nicht abgehauen ist. Das habe ich ganz fest am Arm gepackt, dieses Wort invertiert, dass ich gesagt habe, bleib hier. Du bleibst jetzt hier. Du bleibst jetzt hier. Wenn du mir noch abhaust. Nee, du bleibst jetzt hier. Oh nö, nee, du bleibst jetzt hier. Hat auch nicht geholfen, dass wir komplett auf Englisch geguckt haben und nicht mal Untertitel hatten, nicht mal englische Untertitel hatten, wir hatten ja gar keine Untertitel. Und dadurch, weil Christopher Nolan halt auch so ein Typ ist, der dann halt meint, dann auch so wichtige Erklärszenen in einem Katamaranrennen unterzubringen, wo die ganze Zeit der Wind macht.
Das Beste war, wo die, glaube ich, in einem Hubschreiber waren und nur über dieses Mikrofon-Funksystem geringen.
Aber im Katamaranrennen ja auch.
Die gehen so nur, was, als wäre das noch nicht schlimm, und jetzt erkläre ich dir immer, und dann die Musik. Sorry, alle die Fresse gerade. Was? In der Tür, Bruder, Plutonium, zwei, eine, vierze. Und dann auch noch diese Akzente. So, dann nimm doch wenigstens irgendwie, alle sollen dann zumindest so ganz langsames Hochenglisch sprechen. Nein, dann eine Indische. Der Russe, der nuschelt, wo du keine Hälfte nicht verstehst, sie ist irgendwie britisch, verstehst du nicht, alles, alles furchtbar. Nee, aber toll. Und ich dachte mir irgendwann wirklich ab der Hälfte des Films so, das ist dann so, wie wenn man durchgefallen ist, glaube ich, so wenn man in der Hälfte der Jahresstufe merkt, ich fall durch. Und es ist ja auch eine Freiheit, dann zu sagen, jetzt ist mir alles scheißegal, weil ich weiß, dass ich durchgefallen bin. Und ich dachte mir, so auf der Hälfte des Films... Popcorn durch den Saal. Ja, genau, du denkst dir so... Fuck it. Und dann dachte ich mir bei der Hälfte des Films, nee, du bist durchgefallen, du wirst es klasse nicht erreichen, jetzt geniess zumindest die zweite Hälfte des Films einfach so. Guck einfach, schau einfach zu. Und dann habe ich schon mal geguckt, bei der nächsten Hellenszene, Ende des Films, und dann war es entspannter. Da hat es sich entspannt und hat sich zurückgelehnt. Kapituliert. Mit so einem seligen Grinsen auf dem Gesicht und so hast du die Action genossen wenigstens. Wow, wow, das ist aber doll laut gerade. Auch wenn es schwer ist, die Action zu genießen, wenn man es nicht versteht. Aber es ist, ja, naja. Den ersten Satz von dir nach dem Kino fand ich sehr gut und bezeichnend. Ich habe oft nicht verstanden, was ich nicht verstehe. Ja, genau. Ich habe oft nicht mehr verstanden, was ich nicht verstehe. Ich wüsste jetzt gerade nicht mal, welche Frage ich stellen würde. Also ich bin so weit weg, dass ich nicht einfach so, ganz kurz, ist der in den Raum reingegangen oder rausgegangen? Ach so, klar, dann passt. Ich war völlig, völlig weg, völlig woanders.
Du bist ganz woanders.
Aber ich finde, also es war insgesamt, finde ich, doch ein tolles Kinoerlebnis, weil dadurch, dass wir alles nicht verstanden haben, ist so eine Solidarität entstanden, dass wir vor dem Kino noch diskutiert haben. Und alle haben noch diskutiert vor dem Kino. Und wir haben alle geguckt. Weil der ganze Saal war noch da. Man kann kurz überlegen, kommen wir alle zusammen kurz, erklären wir das jetzt zusammen. Wer hat eine Flipchart dabei, hat jemand einen Stift, das ist nochmal alle. Jeder hat so zehn Prozent verstanden. und wir nur genug Leute zusammen kriegen, verstehen wir alles. Es war irgendwie, niemand konnte nach Hause gehen, weil alle noch rotiert haben, innerlich, und dann haben wir es einigermaßen uns zusammengeflickt, aber nicht ganz. Und ehrlich gesagt, ich habe auf dem Nachhauseweg nochmal drüber nachgedacht und ich glaube, es gibt einfach Lücken in dem Film, ich glaube nicht, dass es konsistent ist, ich will da jetzt nicht drauf eingehen, weil es uns alle sagen, du hast es nicht verstanden, was sehr leicht ist zu sagen, anstatt dass man es erklären muss.
Ich glaube, ich muss ihn einfach nochmal sehen, um meine Theorien zu überprüfen und dann können wir darüber reden, weil ich glaube nicht, dass es stimmt.
Und ich habe auf dem Nachhauseweg, weil ich fand ich auch ganz toll, bin ich nach Hause gelaufen, quer durch Köln und ich habe immer mal wieder so Trauben entdeckt, die wirklich diskutieren. Oder invertieren.
Genau, invertiert.
Und warum, ja, aber warum ist das dann so?
Und es war immer in dieser Gruppe, war immer einer, der es anscheinend verstanden hat.
Und alle anderen, dann gab es doch die anderen 40%, die so, ja, ja, ja, stimmt.
Und die Joker.
So habe ich es mir auch schon gedacht.
Und die Gaggeis.
Und die, die abgesprungen sind und nur Gags machen.
Ja, das ist immer in den gleichen Gruppen. Einer, der meint, er hat es verstanden, dann so Fragesteller, von denen aber einer dann rauskommt, hat es besser verstanden als der, der die ganze Arbeit. Genau, die grosse Masse, die nicht zugeben will, dass sie es nicht verstanden hat und deswegen einfach nach jeder Erklärung sagt, ach ja, das stimmt, genau so habe ich es mir auch gedacht. Einfach um es auch zu enden und diese Diskussion langsam in Richtung, wo gehen wir denn jetzt essen zu lenken und dann haben wir immer noch einen, der im Hintergrund Gags macht. Bei mir war es aber auch so, mir sind so viele, wenn ich es nicht verstehe, dann komme ich auch in so einen Comedy-Modus in einem Film. Nicht, dass ich es jetzt lächerlich mache oder so, aber ich habe dann immer so Ideen, wie man das als Sketch machen könnte oder was jetzt lustig wäre, weil irgendwie allein die Tatsache, dass in dem Film alle gut damit klarkommen auch, was da passiert.
Niemand stellt es in Frage. Niemand sagt so, bitte was? Also diese Erklärszene mit Bella LaCour, die sagt so, ja und dann geht es durch die Zeit und der Protagonist so, okay. Und nicht so, sag mal, wo ist die Kamera, hast du einen Schaden, ist das dein Ernst? Und wirklich auch so, du hast auch das kapiert. Das hat mich geärgert, dass alle im Film das verstehen
und niemand mal mir so, so einer am Rande des Bildes mal so in die Kamera guckt
und so leicht im Kopf schüttelt, so Alter.
Ja, so ein Kamerablick, so ein Alter.
Schulter zucken und so leicht so, einer von diesen Soldaten,
die in diese Mission gehen und der auch so sagt so,
ich laufe da jetzt hinterher.
Ich weiß nicht, ich weiß nicht mal in welche Richtung ich bin.
Ich laufe immer hinterher, wo man passiert. Ich la denen, die auch ein blaues Band um sich haben. Aber das stimmt, bei Interstellar hat das Christopher Donnell noch gemacht mit so einem Comic Relief, dem Roboter, der ab und zu so Dinge lustig gemacht hat. War ja auch ein lustiger Film jetzt, also viele lustige Momente, aber hat sich doch insgesamt ernster genommen. Fand ich aber auf eine Art cool, dass du halt so diese ganze Filmwelt, du kaufst es halt eher, als wenn du die ganze Zeit überlegst, so what the fuck is happening, ja, schon spannend, aber gut, guck dir nochmal und dann reden wir nochmal über deine Lücken, die du gefunden hast, vor allem, ich denke mir auch so, denn, also wir machen ja auch gerade, drehen wir Staffel drei von How to Sell Drugs, so und ich kriege jeden Tag die gleichen dummen Fragen, weil da eine so eine Montagesequenz drin ist oder auch andere Szenen, die ein bisschen komplizierter sind, so und aber auch nicht wirklich. Es ist plötzlich nur, wie kommt etwas von A nach B. Und jeden Tag kriege ich so viele Fragen, wie kann der jetzt plötzlich an das kommen?
Und ich denke mir die ganze Zeit so, erstens steht das im Skript, zweitens, ich bin ein Riesenarsch da auch hinter den Kulissen. Kann nicht bestätigen. Und dann, nee, dann reden wir mit den Leuten drüber und dann ist alles gut. Aber dass es schon so ein paar leicht schwierige Szenen sind, so eine Arbeit und so nervenzerrend, das kannst du dir nicht vorstellen. Und dann denke ich mir, wie kriegt Christopher Nolan das verkauft? Weil das ganze Team, jeder Drecks Vfx-Artist, nicht gegen Vfx-Artist, müsste es ja verstanden haben, welche Richtung jetzt diese Mine geht. Der muss ja die Welt und die Physik der Welt verstanden haben. Wie unwahrscheinlich ist es, dass alle in diesem Team das verstehen. Finde ich fantastisch. Das ist echt, und ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das alle verstanden haben. Ich glaube wirklich, am Set war da auch viel Rätselraten und ich sag das jetzt einfach mal und ... Ich glaube, da hat viel Ja-Sage um sich herum, der Chris. Ja, kann sein. Chris No. Kann sein, kann sein, aber ja, tolles Kieferlebnis. Gefahrener Film. Und was ein geiler Film, um jetzt die Kinosaison wieder an den Start zu bringen. Und was für ein toller Film, um sich toll zu fühlen. Ich habe danach Kino Plus gesehen, die ja relativ offen zugeben, dass sie keine Ahnung haben, es nicht verstanden haben. Und dann habe ich die 29er gehört, Wolfgang Schmidt, der dann meinte so, ja, ich habe dann auch so ein paar Kritiken gesehen von Leuten, die dann meinten, sie hätten es nicht verstanden. Ich fand das eigentlich sehr einfach zu verstehen. Und dann denke ich, okay, du bist Herr Wolfgang fucking M. Schmidt, aber come on, gib uns doch einfach Menschen auch mal eine Chance und sag, ja, das war schon schwierig, aber kann man verstehen. Aber einfach da, glaube ich, müssen jetzt auch viele Leute betonen, wie einfach es zu verstehen doch war und wie leicht es doch war. Aber ich finde, es ist schon schwierig. Ist ja auch okay. Nee, es war schwierig, kein Problem. Gibt es aber, weil manche Websites gibt es so in einfacher Sprache. Gibt es den Film zum Beispiel in einfach? Genau, noch mal in einfacher. Oder mit so einem Untertitel, oder ich hätte mir zumindest gewünscht, dass man visuell Hilfen gibt oder irgendwie so, oder rechts oben immer so einenuen oder grünen Punkt hat, je nachdem in welche Richtung die Zeit gerade läuft oder so ein Pfeil nach oben, Pfeil nach unten, hätte mir schon total geholfen, weil das Problem ist ja, es reicht ja, wenn du mal eine Minute aussteigst und du bist schon verloren, weil du weißt nicht, wer ist jetzt in welcher Zeitebene, bla, das ist ja schon mal schwierig. Einfach nur mal ... Trick, wenn ihr den guckt mit Freunden und clever sein wollt, geht kurz aufs Klo und sagt danach, ja, aber da war ich ja im Klo, da wurde das ... Also, weil du kannst alles auf diesen einen Moment beziehen. Und ganz wichtig, wenn ihr aufs Klo geht, geht rückwärts. Ist ein Lacher im Kino, ist einfach ein Bruder. Weil die Spannung ist so hoch, einfach mal so ein kleiner, macht ihr den Comic Relief. Einfach mal ein kleiner Comic Relief. Ja. Es ist ein Gag. Es ist so ein, aber krass einfach, also da bin ich echt total, das ist wirklich ein Idol in der Hinsicht, Christoph and All, wie der es schafft, so geiles Momentum zu kreieren. Also der ganze Film ist ja so super spannend, wie so eine, keine Ahnung, Gaspedal durch die ganze Zeit und Und die ganze Zeit ist Sonnendrive einfach, das ist so cool. Das ist so, wie eigentlich der Film ist, noch ein bisschen besser, fand ich, als, also von diesem Aspekt Momentum und so, als Dark Knight. Manchmal hat er so Momente, wo so alles zusammenläuft und dann zieht er einen so wahnsinnig krass mit. Und eigentlich ist Tenet dieses Gefühl die ganze Zeit. Ja, ja, crazy. Ich bin auch gespannt, was da noch kommt. Also ob der jetzt einfach sagt, ich ziehe jetzt einfach den Schwierigkeitsgrad so lange an, bis ich keine Filme machen darf. Ja, jeder Film wird ein bisschen abgefuckter, so lange bis Leute sagen, so, wir sind alle erwachsene Menschen, aber schön langsam. niemand mehr was. Nee, nee, nee, nee. Ja, nee, weil wir machen jetzt das Konzept Zeitreise, aber durch Raum, aber halt Raumzeit, aber schon in Zeit, aber durch Raum. Also man ist zur gleichen Zeit an mehreren Orten und die Zeit läuft irgendwann zusammen. Ich muss es aber auch auf How to Sale beziehen, weil dann gibt es zum Beispiel den Job der Script Continuity.
Ein fixer Job.
Die bekommen irgendwann dann auch ganz am Anfang, also wir sind am Set und gucken, dass keine Anschlussfehler entstehen und schreiben Tagesberichte, machen sehr viel und gucken, dass die Blickachsen stimmen, alles. Aber die gucken auch ganz am Anfang die Skripte durch und sagen dann, weil man bet betont ja nicht immer, heute ist Mittwoch oder weil wie auch oder gestern war das oder nächste Woche müssen wir das und das machen. Manchmal aber halt doch. Und diese Timeline muss ja irgendwie Sinn ergeben. Und Script Continuity guckt sich das dann vorher an und teilt dann auch Tage ein zum Beispiel. Und dann sagt dann, das ist bestimmt dann sowas, das ist Donnerstag, das ist Freitag, warum haben die Schüler da jetzt frei, das muss ja
offenbar Wochenende sein, dann kann das nicht nächste Woche passieren, also die gucken das einigermaßen durch und dann kriegt man immer als Autor dann am Ende so eine Liste geschickt mit offenen Fragen, das ist einfach eine große Excel-Tabelle, das sind Rechtsfragezeichen und das ist so schwierig, diese Fragen zu beantworten.
Und es ist immer ein großes In-mich-Gehen und Nachdenken und WTF.
Das ist so schwierig zu beantworten, diese Timelines in den Griff zu bekommen.
Wer zur Hölle macht denn diesen Job bei sowas wie Tenet, wo man sagt, das macht unglaublich schwierig, darauf zu achten, dass irgendwie die Timeline Sinn macht. Wahnsinn, Wahnsinn. Das ist so geil. Man muss ja an irgendeinem Punkt einfach aufgeben, glaube ich, oder? Weil ich meine, klar, natürlich ist es wichtig, sowas zu haben, aber ich glaube, irgendwann sagt man ja, der Zuschauer kriegt das nicht mit. Es gibt ja auch bekannte, grosse Filme mit wirklich grossen Logiklücken, die ja wahrscheinlich irgendjemandem aufgefallen sind und man einfach gesagt hat, ja klar, das wird zehn Jahre nach Release und dicke Junge im Filmfehlerforum irgendwie machen. Aber da ist auch häufig die Antwort dann, da ist so ein rot, dann so ein grosses Fragezeichen, dann schreibe ich, ja komm, ja komm, machen wir so. Ja komm ist ein, nee komm, sag mal, sag mal, sag mal, das ist das Niveau ...
Nee, ne? Auch so eine klassische Reaktion. Nee, ne? Nee, ne? Mache, nicht. Nee, nö.
Ja, genau, aber das ist spannend und irgendwann, komm, ich hab richtig Bock, mal irgendwann einen Film zu machen.
Ja, hast du eine Idee? Irgendwas mit Hunden?
Klar, Hunde.
So der am schwersten zu drängende Film. Es geht gar nicht im Plot. Du hast Kinder, die sich in Hunde verwandeln können. In Hunde verlieben. In Hunde verlieben. Die Hunde sprechen dann auch miteinander. Und alles wird gedreht in Niagarafällen, konstant, in einem Kanu, das auf den Wasserfall zufährt, über zwei Stunden lang und die ganze Zeit so zehn Meter vor dem Abgrund ist. Und in dem Kanu unterhalten sich die Hunde miteinander und müssen halt wirklich Blickachsen stimmen, das Fell wird immer nasser im Laufe des Films. Es sind grundsätzlich, der ganze Cast anwesend sind immer, genau, und alle Zeiten auch. Der ganze Cast ist anwesend, alles echt, keine Special Effects. Und dann die Flashbacks in alle Zeitachsen. Also es gibt die noch immer Flash-Forwards, wo die dann so 90 sind, bis hin zu Flashbacks, wo die noch jünger sind. Heißt, wir müssen also alle Altersgruppen casten. Ja, du brauchst kleine Hunde, mittelgrosse Hunde und richtig alte Hunde. Also wirklich so ein 40 Jahre alter Hund, der so wirklich richtig fucking alt ist, der halt komplett grau ist, der Standardhund ist schwarz und dann brauchst du noch einen Hund, der komplett grau ist, kein Vorwuchs. Ja, das pitche ich dann Warner Brothers. Ich meine, das müssen doch solche erfolgreichen Regisseure wie Christopher Nolan manchmal machen, einfach mal aus Spaß irgendeinen Scheisspitch. Ist nicht Tenet einfach auch ein grosser Joke? Ist nicht auch so, also Folgendes passiert, man hat sich so einen Scheiß zurecht improvisiert und die alle so, keine Wohl verstanden, aber es ist halt Christopher Nolan. Ja, und dann so, Mr. Nolan, what's your next project? Also ich dachte, halt so ein Wiener Würstchen, wo beide Enden halt ein Bewusstsein haben und beide Enden können sprechen. Und im Laufe des Films verlieben die beiden Enden sich dann ineinander, können aber nicht zu sich finden, weil sie ja beide in einem Würstchen sind. Und wissen, dass sie invertiert sind in dieses Senfglas. Genau, und die versuchen dann an sich ranzukommen und drehen sich und dadurch drehen die sich so schnell, dass letzten Endes das Raum-Zeit-Kontinuum schräg wird. Also es ist nicht umgedreht, sondern schräg. Für manche vergeht die Zeit langsamer. Genau, für alle, die weiter links stehen, vergeht die Zeit langsamer als für die, die rechts stehen. Das heißt, wenn man aufholen will, muss man sozusagen nach rechts laufen und kann dann andere in der Zeit überholen. Weil alle wollen ja nach links, alle wollen ja, dass die Zeit möglichst langsam geht, aber dieses Würstchen, dadurch dass es sich dreht, ist sozusagen konstant in beiden Hälften. Wie viele Millionen, wie viele Tauben? 400 Millionen. Ja, okay. Ja? Ja. Talent hat 225 Millionen gekostet.
Naja, weil es ja leicht zu trainieren ist.
Du trainierst eine Szene und machst dir dann halt immer vorwärts, rückwärts, vorwärts, rückwärts, vorwärts, rückwärts. Billiger Film im Kern, machen wir uns nichts vor. Im Grunde total einfach. Vorwärts, rückwärts, zurückspulen, vorwärts, aber eigentlich immer nur diese Rewind-Tasten.
Und im Schnitt war es nochmal rückwärts hier.
Das ist so ein bisschen wie Sabos Episode 4 dieser Tusken Raider, der dann Luke zu Boden wirft und dann so den Speer hochhält, wo die auch im Schnitt gemerkt haben, wir haben zu wenig Footage und dann den einfach immer wieder vor und zurück laufen lassen haben, dass es so aussieht, als würde er diesen Speer immer wieder hoch und runter schütteln. Und dann einfach so immer vor und zurück. Und diese Idee ist quasi Tenet einfach so. Du hast eine coole Kampfszene und dann immer Vorzeuge, Vorzeuge, Vorzeuge, Vorzeuge.
Ja, hat unser Idol Wolfgang Schmidt ja auch angemerkt. Krass, dass man sowas mal im Kino sieht, dieses Zurückspulen, was man ja gar nicht kennt eigentlich so vom Kino. Und wie geil, dass man das Dumber hat, weil das Zurückspulen ist ja so ein Zuhause-Ding. Ja, Harry Potter 3.
Ne, das ist eine Zeitreise.
Zeitreise.
Aber im Prinzip gar nicht so schlecht als Mood für Tenet, weil es ist die gleiche Logik. Weil die Zeitreisenlogik ist die gleiche. Es entstehen Loops, wo du dir selber, wenn du dir in der Zeit zurückreist und dir selber etwas gibst zum Beispiel, hast du es in der Zeit bekommen von dir. Also du weißt schon, dass es passiert. Es ist schon passiert. Wohingegen Back to the Future ja die Zeit verändert. Da reist du zurück und küsst mit deiner Mutter rum. Weird. Würde aber auch jeder machen, oder?
Also wenn man wirklich ehrlich ist und das Gedankenspiel bis zum Ende bringt.
Naja, ich glaube,
es gibt zwei Arten von Zeitreisen.
Die einen, die einfach sagen,
die ihren Auftrag vergessen irgendwie und sich dann so im Alltag verlieren und Milchschnitten essen.
Und früher gab es dann noch Lunchables oder so.
Mentors Energy.
Bleibt dabei.
Die dann einfach in den Supermarkt gehen und sich Lunchables holen,
weil es das noch gab und sich halt irgendwie
Vielen Dank. Da gab es dann noch Lunchables oder so. Mentos Energy. Bleib dabei. Die dann einfach in den Supermarkt gehen und sich Lunchables holen, weil es das noch gab, und sich halt irgendwie in Auftrag verlieren und der Auftrag gibt auch irgendwie, hallo, du solltest den Präsidenten ermorden. Ach so, shit. Wie lange könntest du zurückreisen in der Zeit, ohne dass, also wenn, könnte ich jetzt zurückreisen ins Jahr 2012, gab es Mentos Energy noch. noch. Und mit meinem jetzigen Outfit, mit meinem jetzigen Handy, so kann ich da jetzt hinreisen und mich normal verhalten und würde nicht auffallen? Ich glaube schon. Ich glaube, das ist eh alles Retromässig. Das ist acht Jahre her. Ich weiß es nicht. Wie lange kann ich zurückreisen in meinem jetzigen Outfit, mit meinem jetzigen Handy? Du so extra warst, ist dein Outfit nicht, weil du das jetzt ständig betonstst, du trägst du Jeans und Pullover. Das ist jetzt wirklich nicht so, dass man sagt, boah, was bist du aus meiner Zukunft, kommst du denn? Ich meine genau das, was ich jetzt trage. Was ich jetzt gerade, mein jetziges Dress, mein Outfit, wenn ich das jetzt anziehen würde. Ich glaube nicht, dass es so groß auffallen würde. In keiner Zeit, ne Nein. Du denn mit dir? Nein. Aber alle fragen sich, was denn RTO Ehrenfeld? Nein, ich glaube niemand hat sich jemals gefragt, was auf einem T-Shirt steht, das ist einfach egal. Ich glaube, du kannst auf einem T-Shirt, da könnte deine Lebensgeschichte stehen auf meinem T-Shirt und es würde niemand ... Da könnte ich stehen, ich komme aus der Zukunft, nein echt, nein ohne Scheiß, 9-11 was an Inside Job. Ich glaube, es gibt dann aber auch eine andere Art von Zeitreisenden, die einfach versuchen, die Timeline möglichst stark abzufacken einfach. Zum Beispiel deine Mutter zu schwängern, um dann einfach zu gucken, jetzt will ich mal sehen, was jetzt passiert. Genau, bei Back to the Future würde er nicht existieren. Weil ich bin dann sozusagen mein eigener Vater. Genau, ich schwängere meine Mutter, bevor ich geboren werde, bin dann mein eigener Vater, sozusagen, aber bin ich ja noch derselbe, weil dann bin ich ja halb ich, halb meine Mutter, wie Jesus halt. Oh, haben wir gerade ... Stimmt, hat Jesus selbst ... Nein, sie ist ja Jungfrau geboren. Naja, na gut. Glaubst du nicht, ne? Nee, aber das ist ja genau die Frage. Bei Tenet und Harry Potter 3 wärst du dein eigener Vater, warst es aber auch immer schon, weil es ein geschlossener Loop ist. Stimmt. Bei Back to the Future wärst du dich damit umgebracht, weil du die Teilen einverändert hättest. Dann wärst du auf deinem Bild, was du in der Hand hast, verschwunden. Was du die ganze Zeit hast, hast du ja auch ein Familienbild von dir in der Hand. Ja. Ja, das ist spannend, Zeitreisenlogik. Ich mag das am liebsten, diese Playrider 3. Ja, aber bei Tannin war es dann auch so, dass ich das dann gesehen habe und dann erstmal alle Implikationen durchgedacht hat. So, ah, okay, was passiert dann, wenn so und wenn so und dann war der Film schon irgendwie wieder in der Verfolgungsjagd mit quietschen Reifen. Genau. Und dann so, warum hören die das jetzt? Keine Ahnung. Ja, und dann kam halt der Abspann auch schon relativ schnell. Sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr schneller, langer Abspann. Langer Abspann, ja. Aber super schnell, schwer zu lesen. Wer so schnell sich bewegt hat. Ich dachte, das haben die alle nicht verstanden. Ich hatte bei jedem Namen, das hast du noch nicht gecheckt. Nee, hast du nicht verstanden. Ach, der Kameramann, Heute von Hoytema heißt der. Mega Name, Heute von Hoytema. Mega Name. Neuländer, der macht die ganzen Christopher-Neuland-Filme. Ich frag mich immer, was es braucht. Worauf ich bei Abspann immer am meisten gucke, sind eigentlich so diese Spitznamen. So irgendwie Leonard, Larry, Williamsburg oder irgendwie sowas. Einfach so, wie sehr muss man, weil jeder hat ja einen Spitznamen, aber wie hart musst du Lenny sein, dass selbst im Abspann, weil du bist ja auch Phanta, aber trotzdem steht ja im Abspann nicht Stefan Phanta-Titze. War mein Vorschlag, aber gut, aber also musste genau, aber wer kontrolliert das? Weil du sagst, ich würde gerne im Abspann Stefan Phanta-Titze stehen und dann muss ja irgendjemand sagen, dich nennen niemand Phanta. Ja, aber der Abspann ist ja auch nur in Google Drive, das verstehen ja auch viele, also das denkt man ja oft nicht daran. Stimmt ja, ne? Aber everything begins with a Google Drive, with an absolute blank Google Page. Ja, aber da darf man sich selber reinschreiben. Nee, das haben die Leute, die ja für die Credits verantwortlich sind, für die sie am Ende die Credits machen. Aber man kann schon sagen, die meisten nennen mich Funder. Man kennt ja die Person. Ich habe einen Tag am Set verbracht und du würdest kein einziges Mal Fanta gern. War ein schlechter Tag, weil die Second Unit so, die kennen mich nicht so gut, aber eigentlich nennen mich alle Fanta. Wie sehr muss man recherchieren, um wirklich am Ende die Anführungszeichen Fanta zu kriegen? Richtig gut. Irgendjemand muss das ja entscheiden. Ja. Lenny Kravitz kann er einfach... Die Leute nennen dich Lenny. Die meisten nennen dich Lenny. Nein, die meisten... Das stimmt nicht. Meine Familie nennen dich Lenny. Wir schreiben auf die Türplakate, schreiben wir Lenny Kravitz. Weil niemand nennt dich Lenny. Ja, aber... Ich wurde schon mal oft im Abspenden Tietize geschrieben, IE. Als Gag? Nee, weil man dachte, ich heiß so. Weil da entstehen ja genauso Rechtschreibfehler wie auf anderen. Was ist der berühmteste Credit-Rechtschreibfehler in der Filmgeschichte? Stimmt, kannst du ja nicht mehr korrigieren. Ich wäre so geil, wenn so ein Regisseur mal falsch geschrieben wäre. Ja. Das ist so lustig. Christopher Bowlen? Ich habe das nicht Bowlen. Das ist doch nicht dein fucking Ernst. Jetzt stecke ich zwei Jahre in den Film und dann steht er written and directed by Christopher Bowlen. Aber das finde ich wahnsinnig lustig. Was ist der prominenteste Rechtschreibführer im Sinne von, gibt es mal irgendwo so ein McDonalds, wo einfach McFonnells steht? Ja, So an der Fassade. Ja, und dann so ein Riesen-F. McFundles, what the? Ein Riesen-F vorne dran. Genau so ein, was ist das, der berühmteste, so ein selbstbewusster Rechtschreibfehler, finde ich immer geil, wo offensichtlich in der Kette entweder alle gepennt haben oder alle gesagt haben, no, let's go for the joke. Das stimmt schon, ja. Irgendwie dann wirklich, oder auf so einem Porsche steht irgendwie Forsche oder sowas. Ja, Forsche. Das ist dein Ernst, das ist doch viel aufwendiger, dann noch ein F. Und warum ist es im gleichen Stil wie die Schrift? Da muss doch jemand hingesetzt haben, das gesetzt haben. Aber eigentlich eine gute Idee, sich so ein Lamborghini zu holen und ein Bamboghini und dann einfach so völlig selbstbewusst sein, Bambobambo. Bambolini. Und man sagt es dann auch immer so, ey, hab mir jetzt ein Bambo, Bambo geholt, ein Bambolino. Das ist ja eigentlich schon so gut, so ein Statussymbol, aber das dann falsch sozusagen. Das ist wie wenn du dir so ein, genau, wie wenn so, wie heißt es, diese Autos, die so verschiedene Farben haben, diese Harlequins, wenn du dir ein Lamborghini holst, aber als Harlequin, wo jedes Teil eine andere Farbe hat,
wirklich das coolste Auto, aber mit dem hässlichsten Farbe.
Das ist Selbstbewusstsein. Das ist wirklich Selbstbewusstsein.
Ja, oder so Radkappen, so hässliche Radkappen.
Genau. Ja, irgendwie so Sailor Moon Radkappen irgendwie so. Und dann diese, was man kennt, Sonnenschützer für Kinder, die dann immer so verblicken sind, Lilo und Stitch. Oder so Deutschland-Rückspiegel-Überzieher an so einem Lamborghini. Wow, nicht schlecht, das ist meine Ansage. Bambodini. Bambodini. Und das finde ich ganz cool, wenn man da mal irgendwie so, weil, bist du stimmt. Könnten wir ja machen, wir können ja Podcast-Ufo-Merch machen, irgendwie dann halt die Podcast-Ufo-Lamborghini, wo es halt Podcast-Ufo steht oder so. Das Podcast-Ufo. Podcast-Ugo. Es gibt tatsächlich, das ist vielleicht der berühmte Rechtschaffel, es gibt eine Podcast-Ufo-Folge, die heißt Ugo. Ja! Eine. Und da kriege ich regelmäßig Nachrichten. Ja, aber das ist nicht so lustig. Kannst du das bitte ändern? Nee, die heißt Ugo. Ugo 81 wahrscheinlich. Irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Das ist ein echter Fehler und deswegen lasse ich es auch. Kein Gag, echter Fehler. Echter Fehler. Echter Fehler, kommt auch mal dazu. Warum schützt du dich gerade am Tisch so ab? Ich habe Angst, dass der Stuhl wieder so laut ist. Ob der Raum sich bewegt oder ob es auf einem Schiff wäre oder sowas. Ja, du wirst dich hin und her gerissen. Wieso, wie bei den ganzen Star Trek Folgen. Das ist auch eines der schönsten Gifs, die ich je gesehen habe. Bei den Star Trek Folgen, wenn dann irgendwie beschossen werden, dann müssen die alle so tun, als würde der Raum wackeln. Und es gibt dann einen Gif, wo der Raum stabilisiert ist. Und man halt einfach sieht, wie die alle ganz hin und her wackeln. Wackeln doll. Alle anders. Alle anders, alle anders, auch alle der andere Intensität. Der eine wird wirklich nach die Wände geschlagen und irgendwie Jonathan Frakes nur so ein bisschen, irgendwie sowas, einfach fantastisch.
Jonathan Frakes, alle so ein bisschen. Ja, mega, das ist der, das waren noch geile Effekte, aber es hat sich ja verspielt, wenn das dann ruckelt, das Bild, dann achst du nicht darauf, dass alle unterschiedlich doll durch die Gegend geschleudert werden. Ja, ich war immer in Bavaria Filmstudios, schon im frühen, jungen Alter, weil ich wollte Regisseur werden tatsächlich. In jedem Poesiealbum, das ich unterschrieben habe, war immer, was willst du werden und ich habe Regisseur geschrieben, auch einfach weil ich ein bisschen stolz war, dass ich das Wort aussprechen und schreiben kann, die meisten Berufswünsche, glaube ich, entstehen so, einfach zu sagen, Dompteur, Regisseur. Und dann war ich auch mal bei Babelsberg Filmstudios, die so ein paar Filmtricks erklärt haben für Kinder und so. Und die haben dann auch so diese Szene gemacht mit der wackelnden Kamera oder dann irgendwie so Foley, also diese Soundeffekte machen, dann irgendwie in so einem Sandkasten dann so mit Schuhen so durchgehen oder dann auch so, haben die erklärt, wie ein Filmkuss funktioniert, wie die dann irgendwie ganz, das habe ich bis heute, denke ich da immer wieder dran, dass ich das nicht verstanden habe, wie die dann nur so tun, als würden die sich küssen, wo ich denke, jedem Film küssen die sich wirklich so, es gibt keinen Filmkuss oder vielleicht war das damals noch eine andere Zeit, irgendwie so, ich habe es nicht verstanden, aber ganz merkwürdig irgendwie und da gab es dann auch so Soundeffekte und dann am Ende wurde dann die Szene gespielt, die wir dann als Gruppe, als Museumsgruppe gedreht haben mit Peng, Peng, Peng, anstatt Schüssen. Das finde ich fantastisch. Geht mal nach Babelsberg, nicht jetzt, in einem Jahr, geht mal schön nach Babelsberg. Babelsberg, Babelsberg, sagt man auch gern. Babelsberg, Babelsberg. Es gibt ja echt einige grosse Filme, die in Deutschland gedreht wurden. Alice im Wunderland zum Beispiel. Wurde ja, glaube ich, irgendwo in München gedreht oder so. Das weiß ich nicht. Irgendwie so, ähm, wie weiss ich es? In Babelsberg? Das weiß ich nicht genau. Müsste man auch mal besuchen. Oder Fouhour natürlich, steht in Babelsberg. Unendliche Geschichte. Genau. Deutschland war mal das Hollywood Europas.
War mal was. Ja, ja, aber jetzt ist alles vor die Hunde gegangen.
Und jetzt hast du halt irgendwie, war Mann Siebers.
Mann Siebers.
Oder halt andere Sendungen.
Oder halt genial daneben.
Warum die Armen?
Genial daneben. Also die jetzt auspixen.
Naja, oder halt, keine Ahnung, genial daneben.
War auch geil.
War auch geil. Ja, ich sag ja nicht, dass es nicht geil ist.
Aber es ist halt nicht die unendliche Geschichte. Es ist halt ein anderes... Ich wollte wahnsinnig gern immer mal, genial daneben. War auch geil. War auch geil. Ja, ich sag ja nicht, dass es nicht geil ist. Aber es ist halt nicht die unendliche Geschichte.
Es ist halt ein anderes...
Ich wollte wahnsinnig gern immer mal bei genial daneben sitzen.
Eigentlich schon, ne?
Also, aber in der alten Show.
Jetzt gibt es das ja nicht mehr, ne?
Ja doch.
Jetzt ist es irgendwie anders.
Nee, und Larissa Ries war ein paar Mal da jetzt.
Geil.
Ja, und ich dachte mir so, wow, wie cool.
Das wäre eigentlich mal cool.
Als Kind wollte ich da immer bei genial daneben sitzen.
Und ich dachte, das wäre fantastisch.
Dieser Sonntagvormittag hat mich Comedy-mäßig geprägt. Sonntagvormittag Giener daneben? Entschuldigung? Auf Sat.1, glaube ich, da wurde noch mal viel wiederholt. Da war dann hier Hausmeister Krause, Schillerstrasse, war alles noch mal dran. Die dreisten drei habe ich mir alles noch mal reingezogen. Das war auch eine andere Fernsehzeit, wo ich dann noch am Sonntag die Wiederholung von Schlag den Rat geguckt habe, wo Schlag den Rat eh schon so acht Stunden lang in die Nacht geht, müssen morgen gefrühstückt und wieder Schlag den Rat geguckt, wo ich dachte, was passiert gerade eigentlich? Meine obskurste Erinnerung an Fernsehen war ja die Abschlussklasse. Da gab es ja so von, ich weiß nicht, ob das nur so ein Bayern-Ding ist, ehrlich gesagt, Aber es gab die Abschlussklasse, wo so eine Abiturklasse verfolgt wurde, mit einem schnellen Auto, und die musste weglaufen, nein, also es war so eine Art Mockumentary oder Fake Dokumentation, die aber so getan hat, als wäre sie echt, also so Reality-Fernsehen im Grunde. Die Rekruten. Das ist ja glaube ich ganz echt, aber es war schon, Abschlussklasse war schon gescriptet und so, aber die haben so getan, als hätten die so eine Film-AG in ihrer Abiturabschlussklasse und filmen sich so gegenseitig mit Abitur. Und dann passieren aber halt so Dramasachen, der verliebt in den und der betrügt die und dann hat jemand nicht gelernt und macht eine Bombendrohung und so, damit die Abiturprüfung abgesagt wird und so. Man hätte schon merken können, dass es ein bisschen dramatisch ist, dafür, dass es echt sein soll. Und das ging dann weiter mit Freunde, das Leben beginnt. Und das habe ich dann auch noch weiter geguckt. Und das war dann immer so. Freunde, das Leben beginnt. Freunde. Freunde. Also das klingt fast so ein bisschen am Mahnen. Freunde, das Leben beginnt. Nee, nee, nee. Das klingt nicht. Nee, damals hat man das noch nicht so bestanden. Freunde, das Leben beginnt. Und dann die nächsteel Freunde, das Leben geht weiter. Ja, Freunde, das Leben geht weiter. Leute, Leute, das Leben beginnt. Und dann dritte Staffel Leute, wo bleibt ihr? Leute, ich warte hier schon seit einer halben Stunde. Ganz merkwürdige Serie hat sich auch irgendwo in die Ecke manövriert. Und da war es immer so, dass jeden Tag zwei Folgen liefen. Aber am nächsten Tag kamen nicht die beiden nächsten Folgen, sondern am ersten Tag. Genau, also am Tag eins lauf zwölf, dreizehn, dann am nächsten Tag dreizehn, vierzehn, dann vierzehn, fünfzehn, fünfzehn, sechzehn. Aber es war ein common phenomenon. Das ist ganz merkwürdig. Du hast dann jede Folge zweimal gesehen, aber jeden Tag zwei Folgen gesehen. Also du dachtest mir, okay, zwei Folgen. Aber du hast ja eine Folge schon gesehen. Mogelpackung. Ganz merkwürdig. Ja, richtige Mogelpackung. Richtige Mogelpackung. Freunde. Aber auch entspannt, weil man konnte immer zu spät kommen, weil man die erste Folge ja schon kannte. Also ganz, ganz strange. Oder du machst einen Tag Pause und guckst dann zwei neue Folgen. So, sehr gut. Das war aber auch ganz merkwürdig, weil das die einzige Serie war, so King of Queens, kam halt jede Woche, jeden Tag eine Folge, immer die nächste, aber auch bar, das war die einzige Serie, wo immer so eine Toppelfolge kam. Ganz, ganz merkwürdig. Du hast mir das Video geschickt von King of Friends, wo Patton Oswalt in einigen Szenen nichts zu tun hat und einfach im Hintergrund steht und er sich einfach wie so ein toter Mensch, wie so eine Puppe, da die ganze Zeit in den Hintergrund stellt und wirklich grinst, einfach nichts macht. Patton Oswalt, der den Spencer spielt, einen Freund von Doug, der hat mal in dem Podcast erzählt, dass es da so viele Szenen gab, wo man in der Szene war als Schauspieler, aber schlicht nichts zu tun hat, einfach nur im Hintergrund steht, nur irgendwie dabei ist, ohne was zu sagen.
Und er meinte, ihn hat das irgendwann so genervt, dass er aus Protest mal eine Szene gespielt hat, wo er einfach wie eine Statue ganz still dasteht. Arme runterhängend an beiden Seiten.
Arme, leerer Gesichtsausdruck und nichts macht, die gesamte Szene und halt im Hintergrund steht und nichts macht, um mal zu gucken, ob jemand das auffällt. Und anscheinend ist es niemandem aufgefallen, es ist tatsächlich so in der Folge. Schaut mal auf YouTube. Und Tagessatz von wahrscheinlich so 4000 Dollar. Patton Oswald Pranks oder irgendwie so was heißt das Video, wo er einfach still im Hintergrund steht und beim ersten Mal gucken könnte es einem auch wirklich nicht auffallen. Aber das gibt es ja oft. Und es wurde ja so gesendet. Es wurde so gesendet und man denkt ja oft so, das Leben eines Schauspielers ist so prestigeträchtig und man ist der Star. Nee, oft steht man nur im Hintergrund und tut so, als würde man aus einem Becher trinken und das den gesamten Tag. Ja. Weil Patton Oswalt, der auch Stand-up-Comedian, der ist ja kein No-Name,
muss den ganzen Tag so tun, als würde er aus dem Becher tragen
und geht nach Hause in sein Hotelzimmer abends
und denkt sich, wow.
Aber vielen Dank für dieses Video, weil ich habe viele Gespräche gerade
mit Schauspielern, die sich dann fragen,
was kann ich dann im Hintergrund noch machen,
weil ich habe da keinen Dialog.
Und das nervt mich immer,
weil ich höre die ganze Zeit nur, gib mir Dialog, gib mir Dialog.
Ja, ich, ich, ich.
Und dann einfach dieses Video mal zu schicken, wo Patton Oswalt einfach nichts macht, das ist auch eine Option. Ja, es ist schon merkwürdig. Ich habe dann auch eine Szene gedreht, wo meine Figur dann sich hinsetzt und wo ich dann auch den Regisseur mal gefragt habe, kann ich mich vielleicht nicht hinsetzen, sondern stehen? Weil man kann mehr spielen, wenn man steht. Und er auch so, jeder Schauspieler will nie sich hinsetzen. Nein, du setzt dich einfach hin, Menschen sitzen. Es kann nicht jeder immer stehen. Und ich so, okay, wow. Ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass das so ein wiederkehrendes Thema ist für den Regisseur. Das ist ein Politikum. Aber anscheinend wollen alle Schauspieler immer stehen. Weil es ist ja, sobald du einmal sitzt, ist es schwer, wieder aufzustehen. Du nimmst ja halt die Hälfte deines Körpers. Nimmst du die Hälfte deines Körpers. Naja, so drei Viertel. So drei Viertel. Nee, so ein Viertel. Gibt es aber oft auch in Serien, fällt mir immer, solche Sachen fallen einem dann auf, dass Figuren sitzen und dann irgendwann einfach aufstehen, völlig unmotiviert. Immer unmotiviert, Hauptsache man hat was zum Spielen. Hauptsache man hat was zum Spielen, weil der Schauspieler weiss, gleich kommt der Wutausbruch. Immer was in der Hand auch, immer was in der Hand. Immer was in der Hand und du kannst halt nicht guten Wutausbruch spielen, wenn du sitzt, aber wenn du stehst, dann kannst du nicht herlaufen und dein Körper voller Energie und du kannst gestikulieren und dich vorn lehnen, wohingegen wenn du sitzt, bist du sehr eingeschränkt. Voll, auf jeden Fall, du hast nichts zum Spielen, das nervt, ja gut, das furchtbarebare Leben eines Schauspielers. Wow, so furchtbar. So viel Arbeit, ne, muss man dann so im Sitzen spielen. Meinte auch der Regisseur, ihr habt schon echt einen geilen Job. Und dann wird der Regisseur gefragt so, und wo stehe ich? Und dann ist er so, ja, keine Ahnung, da. Das muss ich jetzt entscheiden, gut. Und dann stehe ich da.
Ja, alles Entscheidungen werden abgenommen, wird morgens abgeholt, wird hingebracht, man muss auch nicht wissen, wo man hin muss, genau, irgendwann steht ein Fahrer vor deiner Tür, dann wird sie zum Set gebracht, dann wird sie da geschminkt. Und wie sage ich das? Ja, halt laut. Halt so, du kannst es sogar vormachen lassen, machst einfach nach.
Das ist aber echt auch so, Manchmal spielt der Regisseur die Szene vor. Ich denke mir, du bist echt ein guter Schauspieler. Ja, das tue es nicht. Eigentlich kannst du so spielen. Ich bin ein schlechterer Schauspieler als du, der nicht zu sehen ist. Ja, sehr gut. Nee, du machst das schon toll. Naja, da wollte ich es nicht hinaus.
Naja, aber auch. Ich höre nur ich, ich, ich. Ich, ich, ich, ich. Also, Stefan, ich habe die Szene noch mal gelesen und ich dachte, mir könnte man nicht ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, und du wartest nur, bis du antworten kannst, ich, ich, ich, weil ich, ich, ich, ich. Weil aus der Figur heraus ich, ich, ich.
Weil würde es nicht viel mehr Sinn machen, dass ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, vielleicht ein bisschen mehr im Bild ich, ich. Ach ja, ich glaube, es gibt zwei Leute, die jetzt gerade nicken und sagen, ja, stimmt. Ja, wir treffen ein bisschen ab. Wir machen wieder, nächste Woche machen wir wieder Tenet. Wir hatten heute alles drin. Wir hatten Tenet, wir hatten Harry Potter, wir hatten die Leiden von Continuity-Leuten, also alles drin heute. Also für alle was dabei. Und Leute, ich meine das ernst. Wir sind da gerade so ein bisschen monotomat unterwegs, weil wir so eine Kack-Realität haben. Wir sind, glaube ich, auch von Tenet einfach noch verwirrt. Wirklich einfach, ich war wirklich den ganzen Abend noch erschüttert. Ich bin die ganze Nacht nicht geschlafen, weil ich die ganze Zeit YouTube-Witz geguckt habe. Und du hast noch einen Deep Dive gemacht, oder was? Bisschen Deep Dive, ja. Aber würdest du sagen, du hast es verstanden? Ich glaube schon, auf die grobsten Sachen kann ich antworten. Na gut, aber ich bleibe dabei, Stefan hat behauptet, er könne euch bei jedem Uhrwurm helfen. Ich will, dass sie Stefan bombardiert mit Sprachnachrichten, die so, halt irgendwie so was wie So, was ist das für ein Song? Da will ich, dass ihr ganz viele Sprachnachrichten steht an Stefan Tietze. Er hat behauptet, er kann jedes Musikreizend lösen. Jeden, jeden Oben kann ich euch erklären. Okay, ich bin gespannt, ich bin gespannt. Vielleicht können wir in der nächsten Folge ein paar... Nächste Woche treffen wir uns hier und ich habe so rote Augen. Nee, warte mal, nee, nee, macht es anders. Schickt mir die ganzen Sachen und dann machen wir in der nächsten Folge, machen wir das live.
Genau, genau, stopp, Arret, nochmal zurück. Schickt mir die ganzen Nachrichten, einfach an zentraler Podcast UFO, schickt mir, wie ihr einsinkt, welche Sprachnachrichten, welche Ohrwürmer ihr entschlüsselt haben wollen und dann machen wir nächste Woche die große Stefan-Pietze Musikshow. Die B-Seite von Bonobo hat mal rausgebracht und das ist eine Hidden Track.
Nein, schon Songs, die man kennen kann. Genau, es müssen schon einigermaßen bekannte Songs sein. Ja. Ich freue mich auf nächste Folge, ich bin sehr gespannt. Und bis dahin wünsche ich euch eine ganz, ganz tolle Woche. Wünsche ich euch auch. Macht's gut, geht ins Kino, habt Spaß und haltet euch an die Vorkehrungen. Ciao.! An Regeln halten. Tschau, macht's gut.
Auch an Ampeln und so.
Naja, tschau.
Mach's gut, tschau.
It's a voice-by production.